[Music]
the phrase exponential growth is
familiar to most people and yet human
intuition has a hard time really
recognizing what it means sometimes we
can anchor on a sequence of small
seeming numbers and then become
surprised when suddenly those numbers
look big even if the overall trend
follows an exponential perfectly
consistently this right here is the data
for the recorded cases of kovat 19 a KA
the coronavirus at least at the time
that I'm writing this never one to waste
an opportunity for a math lesson I
thought this might be a good time for
all of us to go back to the basics on
what exponential growth really is where
it comes from
what it implies and maybe most
pressingly how to know when it's coming
to an end
exponential growth means that as you go
from one day to the next it involves
multiplying by some constant in our data
the number of cases in each day tends to
be a multiple of about 1.15 to 1.25 of
the number of cases the previous day now
viruses are a textbook example of this
kind of growth because what causes new
cases are the existing cases so if the
number of cases on a given day is n and
we say that each individual with the
virus is exposed to on average people on
a given day and each one of those
exposures has a probability P of
becoming a new infection then the number
of new cases on a given day is e times P
times n and the fact that n itself is a
factor in its own change is what really
makes things go fast because if n gets
big it means the rate of growth itself
is getting big one way to think about
this is that as you add the new cases to
get the next day's count you can factor
out the N
so it's just the same as multiplying by
some constant that's bigger than one
this is sometimes easier to see if we
put the y-axis of our graph on a
logarithmic scale which means that each
step of a fixed distance corresponds to
multiplying by a certain factor in this
case each step is another power of 10 on
the scale exponential growth should look
like a straight line looking at our data
it seems like it took 20 days to go from
100 to 1000 and 13 days to go from that
to 10,000 and if you do a simple linear
regression to find the best fit line you
can look at the slope of that line to
draw a conclusion like we tend to
multiply by 10 every 16 days on average
this regression also lets us be a little
more quantitative about exactly how
close the exponential fit really is and
to use the technical statistical jargon
here the answer is that it's really
freaking close but it can be hard to
digest exactly what that means if true
when you see one country with say 6,000
cases and another with 60 it's easy to
think that the second is doing a hundred
times better and hence fine but if
you're actually in a situation where
numbers multiply by ten every 16 days
another way to view the same fact is
that the second country is about a month
behind the first now this is of course
rather worrying if you draw out the line
I'm recording this on March 6th and if
the present trend continues it would
mean hitting a million cases in 30 days
hitting 10 million in 47 days a hundred
million in 64 days and 1 billion in 81
days needless to say though you can't
just draw out a line like this forever
it clearly has to start slowing down at
some point but the crucial question is
when is it like the SARS outbreak of
2002 which capped out around 8,000 cases
or the Spanish flu of 1918 which
ultimately infected about 27% of the
world's population in general with no
context just drawing a line through your
data is not a great way to make
predictions but remember there's an
actual reason to expect an exponential
here if the number of new cases each day
is proportional to the number of
existing cases it necessarily means each
day you multiply by some constant so
moving forward D days is the same as
multiplying by that constant
time's the only way that stops as if
either the number II or P goes down it's
inevitable that this will eventually
happen even in the most perfectly
pernicious model for a virus which would
be where every day each person with the
infection is exposed to a random subset
of the world's population at some point
most of the people they're exposed to
would already be sick and so they
couldn't become new cases in our
equation that would mean that the
probability of an exposure becoming a
new infection would have to include some
kind of factor to account for the
probability that someone you're exposed
to is already infected for a random
shuffling model like this that could
mean including a factor like 1 minus the
proportion of people in the world who
are already infected including that
factor and then solving for how n grows
you get what's known in the business as
a logistic curve which is essentially
indistinguishable from an exponential at
the beginning but ultimately it levels
out once you're approaching the total
population size which is what you would
expect true Exponential's essentially
never exist in the real world every one
of them is really the start of a
logistic curve now this point right here
where that logistic goes from curving
upward to instead curving downward is
known as the inflection point there the
number of new cases each day represented
by the slope of this curve stops
increasing and instead stays roughly
constant before it starts decreasing
so one number that people will often
follow with epidemics is the growth
factor which is defined as the ratio
between the number of new cases one day
and the number of new cases the previous
day so just to be clear if you were
looking at all of the totals from one
day to the next then tracking the
changes between those totals the growth
factor is a ratio between two successive
changes while you're on the exponential
part this factor stays consistently
above one whereas as soon as your growth
factor looks closer to one it's a sign
that you've hit the inflection this can
make for another counterintuitive fact
while following the data think about
what it would feel like for the number
of new cases one day to be about 15%
more than the number of new cases the
previous day and contrast that with what
it would feel like for it to be about
the same just looking at the totals they
result in they don't really feel that
different but if the growth factor is
one it could mean you're at the
inflection point of a logistic which
would mean the total number of cases is
going to max out at about two times
wherever you are now but a growth factor
bigger than one settle though that might
seem means you're on the exponential
part which could imply there are orders
of magnitude of growth still waiting
ahead of you now while it's true that in
the worst case situation the saturation
point is around the total population
it's of course not at all true that
people with the virus are randomly
shuffled around the world's population
like this people are clustered in local
communities however if you run
simulations where there's even a little
bit of travel between clusters like this
the growth is actually not that much
different
what you end up with is a kind of
fractal pattern where communities
themselves function like individuals
each one has some exposure to others
with some probability of spreading the
infection
so the same underlying and exponential
inducing laws apply
[Music]
[Music]
fortunately saturating the whole
population is not the only thing that
can cause the two factors we care about
to go down
the amount of exposure can also go down
when people stop gathering and traveling
and the infection rate can go down when
people just wash their hands more the
other thing that's counterintuitive
about exponential growth this time in a
more optimistic sense is just how
sensitive it is to this constant for
example if it's 15% like it is as I'm
recording this and we're at 21,000 cases
now that would mean that 61 days from
now you hit over a hundred million but
if through a bit less exposure and
infection that rate drops down to 5% it
doesn't mean the projection also drops
down by a factor of three it actually
drops down to around 400,000 so if
people are sufficiently worried then
there's a lot less to worry about but if
no one is worried that's when you should
worry
[Music]